[Music]
yes good in the cafe across the street
I like to apologize for the behavior of
my passion I just feel bad in my brand
for people to think that your mouths
will have been raped but the food that
they serving at easel painting and
mother beaches this mother bitches sons
of my bitch across the street what they
be serving is cevapi and what do you
serve here we serve the kebapi about K
Bobby's kebab is bad give up okay
but okay beat two bath you kidnap me or
look at mouth okay okay Buffy Buffy
Bobby come up here okay Bobby Bobby hey
Bobby knowing that you're giving me give
up give up you guys finally what is the
difference between kebapi and cevapi but
they don't know I have to forgive them
for the bastard mother bitches over
there not serving the cevapi put in the
grilled meat salt chopped red pepper
diced onion cream cosmic ice van why
were you sir and we put in the cottage
cheese the ajvar the kajmak the cream
you know Dennis the diced onions sounds
exactly the grilled meat meat and then
we stir and across the street
[Applause]
for you to try the real good food not
what is son my bitch I'll make sure to
give us the five stars on Yelp